welcome back to 8701
so in this lecture we have a very brief
view at the current status of higgs
boson research
and i have to tell you that we could
spend an entire week
discussing this i just give you the high
level overview maybe the you know 30 000
feet kind of overview of what we know
about the exposure
on the canvas page you'll find a
reference to a summary report which
gives you a little bit more information
than i give you here
but i do think that there's a few things
to highlight and those are the ones
which i'm going to talk about
the first part is that we have
discovered the higgs boson in the case
to photons and also indicates to z
bosons where the zebras and itself
decays into a pair of
leptons electrons and neurons and the
detectors we have available
and here this is an example for atlas
and for cms
they are very good in measuring with
precision the
the energy or momentum of photons
electrons and neurons so this allows us
to then reconstruct
the mass of the higgs boson as it goes
through the decay
and you can see this here this is 125 gb
we construct the two photon final state
so we have fixed to
two photons from atlas you see that
there is a slight bump
over an enormous background so those are
other sources of diphoton events
which are produced in the hydrogen
collider but when you subtract those two
spectra which is shown here data minus
background
you see this beautiful peak of x to
gamma commandments
similarly x to z z
and i put a little star here because one
of the zebras has to be off shell
the zebra mass is 91 gb the mass of the
exposure 125 gb
so 90 plus 91 plus 91 is 928 so one has
to be
a little off its mass peak
and then we look at the case into e plus
and minus
and mu plus mu minus and combination
also so for example for muon events or
for electron events as well
those are shown here and again you have
this beautiful peak
consistent with higgs boson at a mass of
125 gv
and again you have other processes which
contribute to this final state
namely the one where you have the four
leptons coming
from the zebra then itself and or
um from a pair of the bosons is shown
here
there's also processes which mimic the
leptons
in the detector those have to be
evaluated as well and they're typically
shown here in this plot in green
okay so as you can imagine we can
measure the cross-section very precisely
because we can identify those particles
well but we can also measure the mass
and this is shown here
the summary of measurements from atlas
and cms using
those two final states the one with two
photons or the one with four leptons
and you see that measurements are
generally in agreement
and they can be combined to this
measurement of 125 gv
and the best the combined value is shown
here
so this is a precision measurement and
since the exposure mass now is the only
unknown
parameter of the higgs in the standard
model we we know
and can check all other properties
and one is you know the coupling
strengths to the both on which we just
looked at already
or the coupling strength to the fermions
so this is two examples one
it's showing hicks to taut events
top last minus and you see again there's
a lot of
background processes which mimic have
the same signature the signal
but we can find when we subtract the
background from the data
the nexus of event again at 125 gb
so towers themselves decay and the decay
into neutrinos which cannot be measured
at this detectors
are therefore the mass reconstruction is
much harder than in the final stage we
discussed before
that is easier in this final stage here
where we have a higgs into two moons
in the plus c minus the issue here is
that the rate
is very small the number of fixed bosons
decaying to be
very small but there's also a large
amount of background so again very
similar to the hicks to gamma gamma
finance that we looked before we have a
huge amount of background
and here by eyes you don't even see the
bump you see the bump a little bit
uh when you do data minus background
subtraction
so you see this small axis here which is
consistent with redundant standard
deviation so
the likelihood of the background to
fluctuate without the presence of the
hex signal
is about three standard deviation all
right this information then can be used
to interact information about the
couplings itself and this is a beautiful
plot here
which shows the x coupling on one axis
either to the fermions or the bodon
versus the mass of the particle
and so you find your favorite particles
the top the w
z the bottom the tower and the muon
those are the ones where we can actually
measure the coupling um and you see
whether or not this is an agreement with
a standard model which is this
blue dotted line here and you see it is
and that plot here tells me that the
higgs mechanism
is responsible responsible for the mass
generation of this particle
so it might be that there is a mechanism
which is very similar to the higgs boson
which results in the very same
observations in nature
um but it's not quite what we have in
the standard model in order to make
those statements
one has to improve the size
of the error bars here or the
statistical significance or the
significance of the measurements
that is part of our program that's what
we're trying to do
all right in summary again this is a
very high level summary so we measured
the mass
we measured the spin and cp of exposure
we measured the coupling to the z the w
the top the bottom the tau and the muon
we have not been able to measure the
coupling to lighter quark masses
strange charm up and down
we have not been able to measure the
coupling to the lx one
that would be spectacular and we have
not measured the coupling to itself so
in the standard model the higgs boson
can couple to itself
so we have diagrams which look like this
x x x and we have not been able to
measure this
this is not free in the standard model
and this would be you know
closing the argument that the higgs
boson requires mass
or the higgs boson is the particle
predicted in the standard model
giving mass to w and z goes on
if you want you can the strength of the
coupling here is this lambda
this is the lambda term in our potential
so that's what we are trying to measure
in the future
but there's more open questions um maybe
there's more than
one exposure on the higgs adding one
duplet to the standard model with this
potential
is one possible solution to the problem
of generating mars
but you could have very well added two
or n
or triplets or more complicated things
and so the question is
are those maybe realized in nature or
not
um
will more precision tell us something
about the higgs boson
are there the case of the higgs bosons
of non-standard model particles for
example the higgs boson decaying into
those guys here which could be evidence
for dark matter
we have looks we have not seen this but
more precision might give us a different
answer
so that's basically the status or the
summary of where we are with the higgs
boson again much more can be said about
that
and you will see this every now and then
in seminars at mit
or other places
you